hallo mein name ist supernett ich
bekommen wir heute seinen neuen video
verwendete sehr sehr viele youtuber
haben schon videos zu skurrilen essens
kombinationen gemacht die allerdings
trotzdem einige leute feiern das heißt
ich habe mir heute überleg zusammen mit
jude kannst auch das ist julia wir haben
da vorne einige merkwürdige essens
kombination vorbereitet und ich werde
jetzt probieren und würde sagen wie ist
die filme bevor ich das allerdings tue
werde ich meine geschmacksknospen auch 0
bezwungen und trinken ist nicht so klug
wie käse loriot mit käse freunde ich
weiß nicht wie das richtig erkennt der
euro ist kaputt keine ahnung ob man das
richtig erkennen kann aber das ist ein
aufgeschnittener drin liegt eine gouda
oder käse scheibe ich weiß nicht wie man
überhaupt auf die idee kommt so was zu
essen aber ich weiß davon jetzt einfach
mal ab
schon ein
also ich muss sagen eine op an sich mit
diesem mit dieser milchschokolade
füllung ist schon sehr lecker aber mit
diesem käse deshalb von gewissen touch
das passt zu dem neckermann otto also
der orior käse kombination würde ich
jetzt auf einer skala von 1-10 sondern 9
geben was guckst du mich so an dass das
war nicht okay also dafür dass es
wirklich eine komplett absurde
kombination von ss produkten es ging es
recht einigermaßen klar ein bevor wir
das nächste produkt machen trinke ich
den geschmacksknospen
[Musik]
als nächste kombination haben wir einen
apfel mit pfeffer und salz
also ich mag äpfel aber peter mag es
eigentlich gar nicht so gern natürlich
klar in essen kommen dann ist man das
immer so ein bisschen nach mit salz und
pfeffer aber heute wir haben hier
wirklich sondern so ein apfel stück ich
weiß wie man das neue canon kann aber
hier ist zum teil das stück vom apfel
abgeschnitten mit salz und pfeffer drauf
ich kann mir vorstellen dass es
irgendwie schmecken wird weil eigentlich
schmeckt alles mit salz und pfeffer
außerhalb ja eigentlich alles mit salz
und verfahren also ich würde sagen das
ist so richtig weg nein das war also der
apfel salz pfeffer essens kombination
würde ich auf jeden fall ne 10 von 10
geben
da brauchst das gar nicht so blöd gucken
das war wirklich todes lecker also ich
meine immer so ein apfel an sich ist
dann ist es halt sondern etwas süßlicher
geschmack will ich sagen aber durch den
salz und pfeffer bekommt das ganze so
eine gewisse note so ein gewisses extra
also ich weiß nicht ich hab mir videos
von anderen youtuber ein cooles
angeguckt was nie so viele sachen hatten
und da waren wirklich dass alle leute
meinen sogar ich glaube das essen aber
beide sachen bisher waren es aber
freunde vielleicht wird das nächste jahr
etwas anders aber vorher das ist ein
kleines kleines trauriges glücklich
mit butter drauf bist du noch zu retten
ich muss an der stelle sagen dass ich
gewürzgurken an sich überhaupt nicht so
nice bin und erdnussbutter hat sich auch
über alles
also ich habe früher mal gesehen gleich
bei spongebob hey wien etwa terry und so
und dann wieder dann irgendwie so keine
ahnung irgendwie marmeladen mit
erdnussbutter auf dem boden die gestern
sagte sommer problemen kommt wieso man
erdnussbutter
hier können sie sich auch nicht erklären
aber freundlich wird gar nicht lange
drum rumreden wie gesagt nächste erstes
kombinationen gewürzt mit erdnussbutter
haben also der erdnussbutter
gewürzgurken es kombinationen würde ich
jetzt auf einer skala von 1 bis 10
bleibe ich mit zwei geben
es hat halt noch was geschmeckt und
bisschen nach erdnuss das war ganz nett
aber ich hatte halt würzburg und ich
hasse erdnussbutter
[Musik]
die nächste kombination steht aus
popcorn mit tomatenketchup schreibt mir
meine kommentare wer von euch das ist
dass ich habe jetzt eine gabel und werde
jetzt einfach mal einen von popcorn
nehmen wo ein bisschen kennt shop.de
warum also ist schmeckt wirklich nach
popcorn mit tomatenketchup aber bei den
anderen essens kombinationen mit dem
apfel zb mit salz und pfeffer oder das
was wir als erstes hat den hof um
mittäter das war so richtig zum neiße
gefühlt neues produkt das schmeckt
einfach nur selbst oder eine pommes mit
ketchup gegessen und jetzt bis zum kinn
und ist popcorn habe ich menschen sind
sämtlich abstoßen der popcorn ketchup
erstes kombination würde ich glaub ich
wieder auf das cover von eins bis zehn
sondern vier geben
also was guckst du schon wieder zu tun
was für acht ich für meinen geschmack
nur sagen für mich war es eine 4 1 ich
mag eigentlich popkomm das popcorn war
schon richtig scheiße und ich mache
eigentlich kennt aber eher so ein gewürz
ketchup und der das komplett aufgegessen
[Musik]
als nächste kombinationen haben wir
überraschen läuft mit urio dann musste
die oberleitung
ja danke ich dachte ich hätte mir den
orange über den kopf und den
oberschenkeln asn also wie gesagt
freunde haben wir einen orio zusammen
mit orangensaft das heißt sie stellen
den teller mal kurz mal ganz kurz mio
neben den ich kenne das nur mit milch
das sind den urio in milch 1000 dass ich
zum beispiel früher manchmal gemacht hat
war ich hab mir irgendwie müsli gemacht
und dann hab ich mir so eine genommen
darüber zerrieben irgendwie über mein
müsli dann aber okay dann ich bin ja
offen für neues kombinationen orion hier
vorne in den orangensaft schönen ein
drucken wir können aber ein bisschen hin
und her hier damit er sich ein bisschen
vielleicht einsaugt damit und jetzt
essen wir den ganzen tag den ein quasi
und beim ersten rennen im mund fax und
spürt man so ein bisschen den
orangensaft weil die geschmacksknospen
geht geschmacks genossen immer sehr
wichtig aber wie gesagt wenn wir dann
weiter irgendwie haut dann schmeckt man
wirklich nur noch den orion der orangen
sagte wirklich nur den ersten ein zwei
sekunden oder so in irgendeiner form als
geschmack vorhanden also keine ahnung
ich kann jetzt in orio und sich bewährt
basierten orient deswegen würde ich
sagen ziehen von zähnen mit dem orangen
gesagt keine ahnung sieben von zehn ist
er einfach keine gute es kombination
geschmacksknospen
[Musik]
als nächstes haben wir ein marshmallow
mit select schnell oder mit käse und
lecker freuen dich stoppen kennt mich
und ich glaube ihr wisst dass ich mit
hilfe über alles kasse und auch
eigentlich käse also zumindest so ein
käse das haar auf dem käse mögen sie nur
ein fussel auf dem käse was hier kurz
mit dem täglich gewaschen oder was war
da jetzt auch nicht wirst du den ganzen
dem - 20 - geschmacksknospen wieder
befreit tibet runtergeflogen hätte ich
also view bereits gesagt hat banane mit
herd wäre das natürlich nicht sondern
sei eine banane mit ketchup ich weiß
auch nicht wer auf die idee kommen
kannst du mit gabel vielleicht ich weiß
wirklich nicht mehr auf sondern idee
kommt das auszuprobieren banane mit
ketchup zu essen ich mein okay ich habe
letztens zum frühstück rührei mit baby
balla gewesen also ich habe keine ahnung
was ich hier von jetzt in keiner form
erwarten soll
deswegen würde ich sagen es sich das
einfach mal was passiert wenn wir alle
zusammen also freunde der banane mit
ketchup würde ich eine gediegene
von 10 ich liebe catcher freuen und ich
liebe beide war das beiderseits
kombination war so krank ekelhaft
[Musik]
also wie google bereits gesagt hat nur
halt mit erdbeermarmelade ist dass leute
das mit erdbeermarmelade ich würde sagen
ich glaube mir da gar nicht lange drum
herum und ich probierte das ganze muss
probieren
für mich lag die quote mit marmelade
wer ist denn pfannkuchen mit marmelade
bei der kombination röhren mit marmelade
nicht vorher schon gedacht das ist genau
wie marmelade mit käse oder so dass es
ja auch voll voll viele auf ihrem bruder
obwohl das eigentlich so sich einige
leute auch einfach nicht erklären können
es ging echt einigermaßen klar um nicht
sogar zu sagen das war so gar nicht ganz
lecker also ich hoffe jetzt nicht dass
ich mir das in dieser form aufs brot
schmieren werde oder ob ich mit dem
ganzen schon so eine 780 409
[Musik]
das ist eine weitere mit 900 von quälen
als letztes haben wir ohne max mit
frischkäse
[Musik]
wir haben gelesen dass leute frischkäse
mit müsli essen also von daher ich liebe
es max über alles ich liebe allgemeinen
müsli über alles ist eigentlich jeden
tag schade
deswegen ist es für mich jetzt eine ganz
besondere essens kombination weil
frischkäse habe ich schließlich ist ja
früchte zu essen wir sonst eigentlich
nur auf dem brot mit so kräutern und
sowas allem haben aber ich würde sagen
jetzt einfach mal ganz großen löffel was
ist auch weg aber also frischkäse mit
müsli ist eigentlich echt ganz weiß aber
man muss sagen es schmeckt einfach so
die harte milch mit müsli also ich
konnte jetzt auch nicht dass das hp
knapp schmecken sollte deswegen würde
ich dem ganzen auf jeden fall auch in
neun von zehn geben also natürlich das
ganze flüssiger wäre das leid und das
alles hat aneinander gepackt und mir
klebt jetzt noch was an den seen
allerdings war echt lecker und von daher
würde ich an der stelle jetzt auch sagen
freunde
ich würde nun das video beenden
das ganze gefallen hat und eventuell
durch denke hey luca ich esse noch das
so dass es vielleicht ein bisschen
komisch und mein freund von mir ist das
dann schreib mir das gerne in die
kommentare und dann will ich eventuell
einen zweiten teil machen wo ich dann
etwas andere skurrile im zweiten teil
will ich dann einige andere hessens
kombinationen einmal austesten
dankeschön an alle die das ganze hier
immer alles vorbereitet design gemacht
hat und sonst wirklich an der stelle
jetzt einfach auch nur noch sagen